Taylor Swift could sway the presidential
election votes of nearly one in five
Americans a new poll from Newsweek has
found that 18% of Voters would be more
likely or significantly more likely to
vote for a candidate if that candidate
were endorsed by Taylor Swift Taylor
Swift for those who don't know is famous
for writing songs specifically about her
terrible judgment in men so for a
decadent and crumbling Republic that
seems to fit the bill perfectly I'm
Michael nlls this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show we might
go to war with Iran we'll get to that in
a second obviously
pretty urgent news we'll get to that
because I have a take on the whole
situation that I haven't heard from
anyone on the left or the right but
first we got to get to something more
important which of course is the Taylor
Swift conspiracy theory I am not a big
fan of the Taylor conspiracy theories
not because I don't uh believe in some
conspiracies these days obviously the
difference between a conspiracy theory
and the truth is about six months now
but
the reason I don't really buy the Taylor
conspiracy theories is because I'm
inclined to like Taylor I know she's
kind of a lib I know that her songs are
not for me I I I don't think I would
ever intentionally put on a Taylor Swift
song but I kind of like her because
she's normal and she's just kind of
pretty and she doesn't have all sorts of
crazy tattoos and mutilations and she
doesn't you know I don't know she's just
like pretty and she's dating a foot
football player and she sings about
completely Bal and ordinary subjects and
I like that in in a culture such as ours
where you have little NS X twerking on
the Devil Himself and you got that other
rapper lady who's singing about being a
demon and you got that other rapper dude
reenacting a Honus Bosch painting where
people are walking into the mouth of of
the devil and and people are dying at
his concerts and all in in that kind of
insanity and that depraved culture to
just have a pretty little blonde girl
who goes out and sings about breaking up
with her boyfriend and then shows up to
a football game and kisses her football
player boyfriend on the cheek or
whatever that's great I'm all about it
but she also might hand the country over
to the Democrats according at least to
the conspiracy theorists and it's not
just on the right it's not The Fringe
tinfoil hat people who are very
conservative it's it's the left too
MSNBC ran a headline not that long ago
this is on Christmas Day Taylor Swift
could save Joe Biden in 2020 24 no
seriously the musical Mega star may be
the rare celebrity with the cultural
influence to shift the political Tides a
number of people on the right have said
that Taylor is really famous and popular
because the the liberal establishment is
trying to blow her up into being the
most influential woman in the world so
that she can sway the election now I
didn't find that persuasive the pichy
Keenan however who is a wonderful
right-wing writer she pointed out
yesterday if you look at Taylor Swift's
tour dates you
got basically just a constant slew of
performances I'm just looking at her
upcoming performance February 7th
February 8th February 9th February 10th
February 16th February 17th where it
goes on and on and on then all through
February all throughout March all
throughout she doesn't seem to be
working much in April then you go
straight may she all throughout may all
throughout June all throughout
July all
throughout August and then there's a big
break August 20th is her last tour date
scheduled and then she doesn't appear
again until November 14th just what a
week and a half after the 2024 election
so pichy Keenan suggested she said oh
good that's there's a gap in Taylor's
tour schedule here so she can go stump
for Democrats around the country and I I
don't know I pich Keenan's a very a very
uh thoughtful conservative writer it
might be the case that that's just a
coincidence and maybe she's going to go
marry this football player and go on a
honeymoon I hope she does it might it
could be the opposite it could mean she
doesn't want to be touring during the
election season because she doesn't want
to be asked for comment and and she just
wants to kind of lay low in fact I think
that's probably the most likely scenario
Taylor invite endorsed Joe Biden back in
2020 but it was very very mild it was
something like one Twitter post and she
was holding a cookie that said Biden
2020 2020 so I don't know it it by the
standards of Hollywood she seems to be
among the least enthusiastic left
Wingers I think that's so much of her
appeal she's just nice and pretty and
inoffensive so that's kind of what I'm
hoping for I remain a cautious Swifty
not because I listen to her music but I
like that she's normal and gives people
an alternative in our culture to the
particularly crazy brand of popular
entertainment but I could be proven
wrong I don't know we'll just we'll keep
these tour dates over on the side
speaking of artists on the left a group
of climate wackos threw soup on the Mona
Lisa
yesterday they're speaking some sort of
barbaric tongue I don't know if that's
are they channeling demons or something
where I can't quite make out what
they're saying but they are the
climate the climate action Maniacs who
keep traveling all over the world and
throwing soup on Priceless works of
[Music]
art and there's cops there but the cops
oh those oh no those are activists
too where the where the cops where the
where the museum guards where are the
dosant even why won't someone tackle
these people and get them away from a
price less work of Western
Art these people these climate cultists
are like the Taliban blowing up the
ancient Buddha statues the Buddhas of
Boman in
Afghanistan except they're less
Justified at least when the Taliban blew
up the Buddhist statues they were
blowing up Idols you know I'm not
defending it I'm not I I don't think the
Taliban is Justified in almost anything
it does
but at least at least I can
understand why a monotheist might get
rid of pagan Idols here though these
climate cultists are blowing up
beautiful pieces of Western Art or at
least trying to or at least trying to
ruin them with soup why because the
climate cult has always been about
punishing our
civilization the climate cult I call it
a cult because it's like a cultist you
know it's it's it's a a form of religion
a perverted and false religion but it's
a form of religion that has all the
Hallmarks of religion it has the notion
of original sin it has the notion of
redemption it has an
apocalypse it has an eschatology it it
has
everything and in the climate
religion our civilization is the cause
of the fall in in the the climate cult
it's we in the west who have
industrialized we have polluted our
Earth and set the Earth on a course for
utter destruction and so only we can
save ourselves we need to stop driving
cars and stop having babies and stop
eating meat and stop doing anything we
need to stop living and growing and
developing in order to I don't know save
the world so that's why they're not
going to destroy indigenous art they're
they're also not going to destroy Modern
Art because Modern Art also is about
punishing our civilization Modern Art
also is about is about feeling shame and
guilt and and uh looking at ourselves uh
as as uh decadent objects it's about
degrading us so of course no surprise
there whatsoever they want to punish our
civilization and a be the great way to
do it Beyond telling us not de have
families anymore and and destroying what
we eat and destroying how we move and
how we live is destroying Beauty
destroying beauty is is perhaps the most
efficient way to demoralize a
civilization now when you want to
remoralization right when you want to
encourage a
civilization right here in the in the
west you're going to need to check out
woke Teater right now go to woke tat.com
are you sick of companies trying to turn
you into a lib it seems that wokeism is
everywhere it's the air that we breathe
it's the water that we drink that is why
woke tears water has a mission to save
America from the brave new woke world
one sip at a time woke tear water is an
American brand that is making hydration
great again woke tears water is a
legitimate brand of drinking water
bottled here in the United States by
people who know what a woman is while
everyone else's water is just water you
know take it or leave it woke tears
provides a refreshing gulp of laughter
in a world thirsty for sanity I also
like that it's clearly inspired by the
leftist tears Tumblr uh it's great if
you want to try woke tears water visit
woke tears water.com you can hand one
out to your friends you can take it to
class I love it it's just so Brazen and
audacious and in your face it's terrific
indulge today in laughter and hydration
the two things that make life possible
that is woke tears
water.com today speaking of punishment
president Trump's trade advisor Peter
Navaro has just been sentenced to four
months in
prison for doing exactly what Hunter
Biden did well no I'm sorry not exactly
what Hunter Biden did you've probably
seen that Clips you know with the
hookers and the drugs and the guns Peter
Navaro never did any of that stuff not
exactly what Hunter Biden did in that
Peter Navaro never shook down foreign
oligarchs and sold American influence
for millions and millions of dollars he
never did
that Peter Navaro just didn't show up to
testify before Congress that's why he's
going to the clink for four months the
exact same thing that Hunter Biden did
Hunter Biden gets off scottf free Peter
Navaro was asked to appear before the
January 6 Committee in March of 2022 He
was ordered to provide documents to that
committee one month prior he didn't do
either of those things citing executive
privilege this is a top adviser to the
president of the United States and the
Congress has absolutely no right to drag
him before them that would be a major
weakening of the separation of powers
Congress is not not absolute Congress is
not Supreme in the United States
Congress is one of the three branches of
government and they have no right to do
that so now the Judiciary has sentenced
Peter Naro to 4 months in prison He was
ordered also to pay a fine of 9500 bucks
which is a reduction by the way the US
District Judge Amit meta wanted to
sentence him to six months in prison and
and find him
$200,000 that that was what the justice
department requested actually I'm being
unfair to judge Amit meta judge Amit
meta was the one who heard this request
and then and then reduced that but it's
still ridiculous the guy sentenced him
to prison and charged him a bunch of
money for for what Hunter Biden did
Hunter Biden also defied a subpoena to
appear before the house oversight
committee for a closed door deposition
he didn't do it he held a big press
conference in front of the capital about
how he wasn't going to do it then he
made a big Hollow blow inside the
capital later on but how he wasn't going
to do it and he gets off scott free
completely Lawless what's the point of
this the point of putting Peter Navaro a
very amiable economic adviser into
prison is to demoralize the right it's
to discourage people ever from working
for Donald Trump even in senior White
House positions it's dis to discourage
anyone from ever contradicting the
liberal ruling class because they'll say
yeah if you if you have a difference of
opinion on trade I mean think about this
Peter Navaro he's he's a protectionist
Peter Navaro was the pro tariff adviser
in the Trump White
House and the liberal establishment is
globalist a lot of the the Trump
election was was about opposition to
globalism just as the brexit was about
opposition to globalism just as Victor
Orban in Hungary his election was about
opposition to globalism just like
Georgia Malone's election in Italy was
about opposition to globalism and the
lives they love globalism they hate
National borders they hate National
sovereignty they want to break all of
that down and have us all just be
governed by The Blob and so they go
after this guy in particular Peter
Navaro and Navaro has stood very firm he
just went on TV to explain that throwing
him in the clink is about a lot more
than just him if anybody thinks U
they're not trying to put Donald Trump
in prison for 700 years they need just
need to look at what they did to me
yesterday they're not messing around
four months in prison they they even
want to put me in prison before I can I
can have my appeal in this case uh and
they want Trump in prison and out of the
Oval Office and they want folks like me
um not to be able to help him out and
here here's the thing here's what I'd
ask your viewers to understand I am it's
not rare I am the first senior White
House adviser with they call alter to
the president ever ever to be charged
with this alleged crime and the irony
here Sean the irony is that the
Department of Justice itself has
maintained a policy for more than 50
years that says that senior advisers
like me absolutely Ely cannot be
compelled to testify before Congress why
because it violates the Constitutional
separation of powers and interferes with
the ability of executive privilege to VI
to provide effective presidential DEC
decision-making totally right if the
Congress can jail senior presidential
advisers for refusing to give them
whatever they want and show up whenever
they want that is an obliteration of the
separation of of powers rather than
having three co-equal branches of
government the legislature the executive
and the Judiciary now we've just got a
supreme
legislature and the executive works for
the legislature the president works for
the Congress that's not what I learned
in civic's class but no one learns
anything in civics class anymore Peter
navara's Point really brilliant here so
how do you make sense of that how could
the doj which for 50 years has maintain
this policy of saying that the the
senior White House advisers can't be
compelled to testify before Congress and
provide documents to them how could the
doj then simultaneously prosecute a
trump senior White House adviser for
doing that because they don't view the
Trump White House as legitimate that's
why you want to talk about election
deniers and deniers of the legitimacy of
our sacred democracy it's the Biden
White House it's the doj that's doing
that they don't view Peter Navaro as a
normal senior White House adviser
because they don't view Donald Trump as
a normal president they don't view any
of them as legitimate so they anything
can be done to Trump and it and in their
minds it won't upset the Norms of our
sacred
democracy Yeah in our sacred democracy
we usually don't jail the opposition
leader but Trump's different we can't
normalize him yeah in our democracy we
usually don't jail former presidents but
Trump's different he was he's not a real
president he's a fake president his
voters they're not real Americans
they're deplorable irredeemable
Americans they don't deserve any rights
jail them too you know any of them if
any of them happen to be walking even
within five miles of the capital that
day you know maybe they were going to go
get a drink at Old ebot's Grill but yeah
just go get round them up too some
Midwestern granny was taking pictures on
the National Mall yeah get her too none
of these people are legitimate you
you're not legitimate you're a
deplorable
irredeemable you you oppos Joe Biden
you're a threat to
democracy that's what this is about that
that's the way it does make sense is the
problem it it makes sense if you accept
their very dangerous premises that half
of the country is not not legit or
entitled to political rights now
speaking of Law and Order a clip from a
Law and Order episode has just gone
viral this is Law and Order has been on
the air I think for 150 years at this
point I think Law and Order predates the
invention of the television Law and
Order has gotten consistently more and
more woke as the culture has gotten more
and more woke uh there's a scene that's
gone viral of a
woman being interviewed by cops and
she's been raped she was raped by a
black man
but she doesn't want to prosecute him
because of her white
privilege but Natalie J Watson raped
you you think I
forgot how could I this entire trial has
been an exercise in reminding me and
this is your chance to do something
about it I am going to believe me
because I can I can afford therapy I
have that luxury and maybe one day
I'll be
okay but if that
teenager goes to
prison you may not
be
ever I don't want
that
natal
wait everyone's making fun of this clip
I don't know why they're making fun of
this clip that seems very accurate to me
that's that is exactly how liberal white
women
think
yes I think it was Robert Frost who said
a liberal is a man who can't take his
own side in a quarrel absolutely that's
how a lot of liberal white women in New
York City would think yes I've been
victimized but but the the man who
victimized me is black and I'm white and
so I must have done something wrong I
must have been asking for it even even
if I was and I've got so much privilege
we can never punish anyone certainly not
if that person is black you can't punish
them they're great great great great
great great great great great great
great great great great great
grandparents might have been slaves or
something so we can't punish criminals
if if we send that man to
prison
he he what he what he might be reformed
that's that's the thing that might
happen of course the the woman the
character is wrong in what but I
actually think the Law and Order episode
is pretty accurate on how white liberals
talk about race and Justice and crime
and all that stuff of
course now in real life what would
happen is this woman would say no don't
prosecute this man or probably the da or
someone say no don't prosecute him he's
black he lives in the inner city he
can't we can never hold anyone
accountable for Crime there and so he
would be released and then he would
immediately rape someone again and he'd
probably do it like 10 or 20 more times
and then maybe maybe he'd go to prison
for about 5 minutes but then he'd get
out on parole and he' go do it a bunch
more times too that's what would really
happen so it wouldn't help
anyone if if he were punished there's a
chance he might be reformed I know
people have' have gone to prison for
more serious crimes than that actually
and who have been reformed and lived
good lives so you can do it it's called
a correctional facility the point is to
correct you but uh what what we're told
now by the libs is the complete opposite
what we're told now by the libs is that
uh if you're held responsible for your
crimes uh you will it will destroy your
life and if you're not held responsible
you'll somehow magically clean up of
course of course that is not the case
but that is an accurate reflection of
the culture good job good job Law and
Order you got it right speaking of white
guilt Senator James Langford who is a
republican ostensibly uh is very upset
about the
GOP killing a killing a potential border
deal with the Biden Administration
it would be absolutely absurd for me to
agree to 5,000 people a day this bill
focuses on getting us to zero illegal
Crossings a day there's no amnesty it
increases the number of border patrol
agents it increases Asylum officers it
increases detention beds so we can
quickly detain and then Deport
individuals it ends catch and release it
focuses on additional deportation
flights out it changes our Asylum
process so that people get a fast Asylum
screening at a higher standard and then
get returned back to their home country
this is not about letting 5,000 people
in a day this is the most misunderstood
section of this proposal okay we'll get
into what he's talking about here with
5,000 in just a second but it sounds
pretty good doesn't it it sounds oh no
it's going to reduce the crossings and
it's going to increase deportations this
bill it's so misunderstood this is the
bill that Mitt Romney is pushing he Mitt
Romney is complaining that that mean old
Donald Trump he's encouraging Republican
Senators to kill the bill and all the
the squishy Republicans are pushing this
kind of Bill but but some of them you
know James Lankford here I don't I don't
want to just write him off as a squish
he's saying no it's really good it's
going to reduce illegal immigration oh
man it's Lucy with the football all over
again isn't it isn't
it I don't care what the bill says and
we'll get into what it says in a second
I don't care what it says there can be
no deal with Democrats On the Border
because the Democrats are currently
breaking the
law okay it'd be one thing if this
problem just popped up out of nowhere
and you know the Republicans and
Democrats have different sort of
interests but we're going to come
together and come to a compromise and no
there's a law already on the books there
are lots of immigration laws already on
the books that the Democrats are
intentionally
violating and we're supposed to
negotiate with them there can be no good
faith negotiation there there there can
be absolutely no trust that they'll
fulfill any of their obligations in in
this bill they're not fulfilling their
obligations under the current law there
can be no deal the deal is completely
dead on arrival any Republican who votes
for this this bill should be thrown out
of Congress should be thrown out of the
Republican party it's a joke if if these
I I don't want to ascribe to malice that
which is explained by stupidity but I
don't want stupid Senators either if you
seriously believe that the Democrats
currently breaking the law are going to
magically start enforcing the law with
all the promises that they're making you
if you just sign one more bill then
you're useless get out of Congress get
out of the Republican party speaking of
the Border crisis America is currently
experiencing an invasion with millions
of illegal aliens flooding our border
under the Biden Administration as Texas
fights the surge Arizona's Governor
remains silent as Biden pursues his
perverse agenda bench buau traveled to
America's Southern border to reveal the
depths of the crisis what he discovered
is shocking it is Criminal it is our
duty at the daily wire to share the
truth take a look at the Invasion on the
southern border America is currently
experien experiencing an invasion a lot
of people coming in from usbekistan
Afghanistan Iraq Syria is there a fairb
of gang affiliation among all always
these people are just crossing the
border illegally waving their hands in
the air at our cameras saying hey here I
am come get me we're no longer the
border patrol we're the welcome control
the number one site in America for fenel
trafficking across the border and if Joe
Biden remains in office it's only going
to get worse I'm Ben Shapiro and this
The Divided states of Biden Invasion on
the southern border watch now on
dailywire plus our Southern border is
wide open the blame rests squarely with
Joe Biden join Ben on the ground as he
uncovers the truth of one of the most
destructive presidencies in American
history watch Invasion on the southern
border streaming now on dailywire plus
what's in this deal this supposedly
wonderful deal that the Republicans are
going to reach with Joe Biden to solve
the problem on the border well as
Senator Langford and Democrat Senator
Murphy have a deal to expand legal
immigration Levels by an additional
50,000 green cards annually and then to
expedite work permits for illegal aliens
who have been released into our nation's
interior and then to provide taxpayer
funded lawyers for unaccompanied miners
illegal alien Miners and then this is
the part that Senator Langford is
disputing but other senators are
are celebrating which is allowing up to
35,000 ille aliens to arrive at the
border every week before imposing border
controls among other
aspects forget the 35,000 a week let's
say senator langford's right forget
about the the anything having to do with
illegal immigration in this bill the
bill expands legal immigration Levels by
50,000 green cards and expedites work
permits for current illegals that's bad
that's bad we have too much immigration
period I have nothing against immigrants
some of my family were immigrants some
came here before the immigrants but some
were immigrants and so I I have nothing
against them personally but we have too
many of them we take a million legal
immigrants a year and now we're taking
millions and millions of illegal
immigrants 3 million illegal immigrants
a year probably it's too much since 1965
when the Democrats blew open our
immigration
policy we between 1965 and 2015 we took
million people
in legal illegal doesn't matter that's
the largest movement of people ever in
recorded history since 2015 the numbers
have spiked we've got 6.2 million
minimum according to the CBO during
Biden's presidency illegal plus another
3 million legal so now we're at what
upwards of N and a half migrant it's
just too many people it's a country of
320 million people it's too much you no
no polity could take that many people in
from different cultures and assimilate
them and we don't even try to to
assimilate them it's the end of the
country this is not some Modern nativist
racist hillbilly you know yokal kind of
stuff this is perennial political
philosophy going back to Plato it just
doesn't work when you let a ton of
foreigners into your country so no sorry
guys I know for a long time Republicans
have maintained this position on
immigration they say illegal immigration
is bad I mean we're going to squish to
the Dems and give a lot of amnesty
usually but but it's bad we're at least
going to say in principle it's bad but
legal immigration is always good we're
all for as much legal immigration as
possible even president Trump who has
been the best on the immigration
question of any Republican president in
my lifetime even he said we want to kill
illegal immigration but we want more
legal immigration than never well he's
half right we do want to kill illegal
immigration obviously of course we want
to enforce the law but we also have too
much legal
immigration and it it's it's not the
immigrants fault it's not the current
immigrants fault it's just that we the
Democrats let way too many people in
it's caused a ton of social problems and
we need to assimilate people before we
can let anyone else in or before we can
let anywhere near these kind of levels
of people in sorry it's just too much
it's called Prudence you know it's it's
the the number one political
virtue is Prudence okay being wise here
so it's it's a terrible Bill all around
any Republican who votes for it is a
total joke and should be thrown out of
politics speaking of Foreign Affairs
we've got the the most disturbing story
of the weekend uh three American Service
members were killed over the weekend and
many more were wounded in a drone strike
by iran-backed terrorists in
Jordan uh President Biden explained what
happened on Sunday uh awful attack and
now you've got a lot of people banging
the drums for war with Iran and of
course if you know if it wasn't Iran
directly but it was Iran backed
militants used a drone to attack and
kill some of our our service members
that's very serious so the question is
what do we do now do we retaliate at all
how do we retaliate some people are
calling for a strike on tyan on the on
the capital of Iran is that what we're
going to
do I don't know that that's a wise idea
I don't know that that's a wise idea at
all because what's going to happen it's
probably happening already is the us is
going to blame Iran
for its terrorists that has funded
attacking US troops and Iran is going to
blame the United States for the war in
Israel and and the reason for that is
that we fund the Israeli military
something like 6 and a half% of the
entire Israeli military budget comes
from the United States it's what is it
$3.8 billion in military funding per
year and now then people will say well
yeah we back Israel because Israel
surrounded by terrorists and they got
attacked and there was a major Pome on
October 7th and so we're going to back
them sure and but I'm not talking about
anything of the morality of the war or
the attack I'm talking about who the
belligerant are if the United States
blames Iran for what its proxies do then
Iran and a lot of other Arab states are
going to blame the United States for
what its proxy Israel does because we're
the ones funding the war without
American Funding there is no war so the
Hawks say bomb everyone and the doves
say never go to war ever
and what I say I guess is the least
popular view of all because I'm not a
hawk and I'm not a dove I I try to
follow Prudence in foreign affairs my
view as I've said from the very
beginning of this conflict is we need to
contain the war so it doesn't escalate
to the point that we will be impelled to
intervene we're already there the longer
the war drags on the more likely it is
that Iran is going to attack American
troops because we have bases all around
the world because we're a global Empire
we have bases in the region and we're
funding Israel
so Iran Iran just as we know that that
the way to stop all of these little
terror cells these jihadis who keep
attacking us is to go after Iran Iran
knows that if they really want to stop
the state of Israel not drawing any
equivalence between the state of Israel
and the Jihadi terrorist cells but they
know that the way to get people is to go
after their backers and they know that
we're the biggest backer of Israel so
the likelihood of attacks on American
troops in that region is going to it's
going to continue to escalate the longer
this war drags on so the question for
the Israeli government is how does this
War end what does Victory look like and
when is that going to
be the annexation the Israeli annexation
of Gaza is not a matter of us strategic
interest it is a matter of Israeli
strategic interest if I were BB
Netanyahu I would recognize that the
only way to have a real security
guarantee in that region is for Israel
to Annex Gaza there's not going to be a
two-state solution the gazans are not
going to have some thriving polity Hamas
is not suddenly going to become a
responsible government it's never going
to
happen
so from the Israeli
perspective the the greatest security
guarantee would be to Annex
Gaza but if they're going to do that
then they've got to just do it I I don't
even really have any problem with that
in principle in that I don't think Hamas
is particularly good for the gazin so
okay if they're going to do it though
they have to do it the the question from
the American perspective is when will
this war end and therefore thereby
reduce the likelihood of more and more
attacks on American
troops is is it in the US strategic
interest to just attack Iran that's what
Lindy Graham seems to think Republican
senator from South Carolina he says hit
Iran now hit them hard John cornin
Republican senator from Texas says
Target
Tyron now let's say let's say that you
are of the opinion
that war with Iran is in America's
strategic interest you've convinced
yourself that if we go in hit them
really hard maybe push for regime change
maybe escalate this conflict in the
Middle East that's somehow that's going
to serve the American in interest not
only Protect US troops but protect the
American Homeland okay then you got to
ask yourself another question do you
trust Joe Biden to conduct such a
war let's say You're really bought in
and you think no we're going to we just
need to project a massive amount of
strength in the region
and and that's going to protect us you
really trust Joe Biden to do that I
don't and then you might say well
Michael you you know we can't just uh
have our entire foreign policy be
contingent upon the men who are leading
the country uh yes we can you go to war
not with the Army you want but the army
that you've got and the Army is doing
great unfortunately the top brass at the
Pentagon are not so great and the
commander-in-chief doesn't know what his
name is let's check in for a second as
we mul a war with Iran and expanding
this this conflict in the Middle East
into potentially a major regional or a
global conflict let's check in and see
how the commander-in-chief is doing beer
brw here it is used to make the Brew
beard in
this oh Earth Rider thanks for the great
legs thank you Mr President really
interesting that's not even some old
clip that I pulled up just to take a
cheap shot at him that was three days
ago in
Milwaukee I don't see how any reasonable
person can convince himself that an
expanded war in the Middle East
attacking Iran the major regional power
is smart right now I just don't see
it I don't if you figure it out please
please explain it to me if you figure
out what Joe Biden just said there in
Milwaukee please explain to me what he
said I'd love a translation now the
foreign policy
Hawks uh just even to to further
undercut their
credibility don't seem to be the
brightest bulbs in the shed they don't
seem to really know what's going on Adam
kininger you remember him former
congressman who his Twitter page now
says his name is Adam kininger
parenthesis Slava ukraini and then the
American flag and the Ukraine flag and
the Israel flag I guess I was about to
say that makes him one of the few
pro-israel Democrats I forgot though
that he's not actually a Democrat he's a
republican who just sides with the
Democrats a lot very confusing stuff he
responds to uh Attorney General Ken
Paxton in Texas who said there's no way
that Texas would have joined the union
if that meant we couldn't protect
ourselves from The Invasion at the
southern border kininger says you didn't
join the union you lost the war
idiot a little history lesson for Adam
kinzinger Texas most certainly did join
the union Texas was a republic before it
joined the union before that Texas was a
hapsburg territory but for 10 years from
1836 to 1846 Texas was a republic and
then was annexed and then became a state
it reminds me of this line from the Bak
by Ides which is talk sense to a fool
and he calls you foolish the people most
likely to volunteer their uh insults and
call you a big dummy and an idiot and a
fool are the people who themselves don't
know anything this guy doesn't know
anything about very recent history of
the United
States this this reminds me of a great
piece of advice from nor McDonald which
I'll get to in one second first though
my favorite comment yesterday is from
mural Emperor 5639 who says can't wait
to watch some Mike's Tom McDonald
reviews yes uh last week my producer
said Michael you got to review this new
song by Tom McDonald and I said okay
well when did when did my channel become
a Tom McDonald review Channel I don't
know sometime then we change the channel
and everything uh but then they played
the song and I finally I
realized Ben Shapiro is rapping in the
song and I thought it was AI it's not AI
so we've got my reaction to to their
song Totally without any forn knowledge
that is up on my YouTube Channel right
now the the late great nor
McDonald once had a bit where he uh he
was turning to his sidekick and he said
you know I was reading this history
textbook and uh you're not going to
believe it it turns out the good guys
have won every single War
ever and and if you read a history
textbook that's true that's true because
famously history is written by the
winners and when someone like Adam
kininger or any of these uh liberal
establishment supporters in the Democrat
Party or in the Republican Party they'll
mouth off on History a lot they'll give
you their Grant view of history and the
history of the United States and then
they will occasionally reveal that they
don't know very much about history most
people don't know very much about
history it's okay I don't know very much
about history we don't we don't learn
history anymore we haven't for some time
in
America but they won't know basic facts
like Texas was a republic before it
joined the union they won't know basic
things
because perspectives on History change
over time if if you asked uh
an average
American a 100 years ago describe the
history of the United States they would
give you a completely different story
than an American today it'd probably be
a lot more positive frankly you ask you
ask the average American today talk
about American history they'll say well
first we killed all the Indians then we
enslaved all the blacks then we were
really mean to the women then we were I
think we were mean to the homosexuals
too and we're just rotten and terrible
give me a can of soup so I can throw it
on some artwork that's what they would
say today you asked them 100 years ago
probably it would be a little different
you asked them 100 years before that it
would be a little a little bit different
still And in 100 years from now our
perspective not on just history but on
ourselves who we are is going to change
people will see the past and the present
and the future quite
differently the people banging the drums
for war just like the people banging the
drums to throw Trump in prison just like
the people banging the drums
to delegitimize the deplorable
irredeemable half of Americans who are
not
liberal those those people have a highly
polemicized view of History they're
going to justify it by history but it
doesn't mean their history is correct
even this phrase liberal democracy or a
liberal democracy that's a term that
basically no one ever used until the
1930s it didn't at all become even
slightly popular till the 40s it didn't
take off until the 1980s okay none of
our founding fathers considered us a
liberal democracy none of the Statesmen
who built our country up until the
middle of the 20th century called us a
liberal democracy now we're told that's
what it is and that color the way that
we behave and the way we treat our
government these things are greatly
subject to change and there're going to
be people in the future who make fun of
us for believing what we do now about
about history and government
now speaking of local government a Rhode
Island School Board has just made an
audacious claim that would make all of
our founding fathers roll over in their
graves which is that parents should not
be notified of their CH children's
sexual behavior in schools I don't think
parents should be notified simply
because Society assumes that every child
has a well meaning family culture that
is accepting of this sometimes the worst
thing you can do is involve a parent in
some of these issues based on their own
beliefs and their own culture and put
pause right
there sometimes the worst thing you can
do is involve a parent in some of these
decisions based on that parent's own
belief and
culture so she's speaking very vaguely
here she doesn't quite Express that
she's talking about lgbtq issues until a
little bit later but that view is very
very popular among the Liberals and it's
at least an admission that there's a
difference between the culture of the
public school culture meaning like to
cultivate like how your kid is going to
be raised there's a difference between
that culture and the culture that many
parents have at home there's a big
difference between the beliefs being
pushed in public schools Where Your
Children Are Being indoctrinated by
these beliefs and the beliefs held by
those kids families there's a big
difference here and when when a conflict
arises they're going to go with their
own beliefs and they're going to
override the beliefs of parents keep
going will cause that student to commit
suicide and there it is put pause right
there
again this is the second thing we hear
especially in the debate we hear if you
don't side with the Liberals if you
don't suppress the conservative beliefs
the traditional beliefs your kid's going
to kill himself the the worst kind of
emotional manipulation I've ever heard
but it's effective even me I'm I'm
pretty immune to this God forbid I ever
heard this from a from a teacher or
something I don't think I would for
reasons that we'll get to in just a
moment but if I did I that would scare
the Daylights out of me I would have to
take a but say am I totally wrong should
I totally C on my beliefs I don't that's
you you've threatened me with the
scariest thing I can
imagine and that's what they do they say
yes you got to side with us you can't
ever side with the parents if you side
with the parents you're going to kill a
kid keep going if you tell a student
who's trusted you who has come out to
say that I'm
lesbian and you now go back and tell the
parent that child has no faith in that
school system ever again and will never
come forward with any
information and his second
recommendation or the third
recommendation pause this is a little
subtle point but she says and if that
student says She's a Lesbian but that's
not really what we're talking about here
is it when we talk about lgbtq element P
we're not talking about the the
16-year-old girl who you know kisses a
girl at a party after truth and dare and
think she's a lesbian for 3 Days know
that's the most anod version of it which
is why this is what this manipulative
liberal woman is doing she won't say
what we're really talking about which is
um homosexual men who engage in Far
riskier behaviors than lesbians and we
won't talk about the real thing that
everyone's talking about which
[Music]
is when you send your kids to a public
school today you are signing that kid up
for the possibility of having his
genitals chopped off simple as not being
hyperbolic not not being provocative
just for the sake of doing
so that's what they think that's what
the liberal schools think that's what
the broader liberal culture thinks
that's what the federal government
thinks is that that's just who they are
if he's a boy and he thinks he's a girl
that's just who he is and the schools
and the government institutions have
have a a right and a responsibility to
keep that information from the parents
to hide this information from the
parents and to encourage the kids to
harm themselves that's what they're all
saying out in public you can't say you
weren't warned and we all saw this
during Co too that's what it means today
maybe you went to public school I went
to public school doesn't mean what it
used to mean that's what it means today
they're telling you that risk when they
tell you who they are you got to believe
them the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code nkw a check out for 2
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans